adriana recopiló datos sobre los
porcentajes de victoria de distintos
equipos y el promedio del salario anual
de sus entrenadores principales en
millones de pesos entre los años 2000 y
2011 después gráfico el siguiente
diagrama de dispersión y su línea de
tendencia suponiendo que la línea
refleja correctamente la tendencia de
los datos que significa que la ordenada
al origen de la línea sea 39 así es que
aquí tenemos un diagrama de dispersión
de todos los datos que recopiló adrián a
y en este eje tenemos el salario en
millones de pesos y cada uno de los
puntos es un entrenador por ejemplo aquí
tenemos un entrenador que ganó más de 4
millones de pesos y su equipo ganó más
del 80 por ciento de sus partidos por
otro lado por aquí tenemos otro
entrenador que gana aproximadamente un
millón y medio de pesos y su equipo gana
un poco más del 85% de los partidos
entonces cada uno de estos puntos es un
entrenador distinto y estamos graficando
el porcentaje de victorias de su equipo
con respecto al salario del entrenador
en millones de pesos
ahora suponiendo que la línea refleja
correctamente la tendencia de los datos
y es una suposición que no nos queda tan
claro que sea verdadera porque por
ejemplo aquí tenemos varios valores
atípicos que se alejan muchísimo de lo
que predice el modelo es cierto estos
datos y parecen tener una correlación
lineal positiva
pero los datos están bastante dispersos
y por aquí tenemos muchísimos
entrenadores que ganan menos de medio
millón de pesos al año y su porcentaje
de victorias tiene un rango muy amplio
desde el 20% hasta el 60% pero bueno
suponiendo que la línea refleja
correctamente la tendencia de los datos
que significa que la orden nada al
origen sea 39 bueno pues eso de que la
orden nada al origen de esta recta la
línea de tendencia sea igual a 39 si
nosotros creemos lo que dice este modelo
lo que significa es que si un entrenador
gana 0 pesos al año
el modelo espera que su equipo gane
aproximadamente el 39 por ciento de los
partidos claro con un amplio margen de
error claro que este es un caso poco
realista porque no esperamos que ningún
entrenador gane 0 pesos al año pero
bueno ahora sí vamos a ver qué opciones
tenemos para ver cuál de ellas describe
qué es lo que estos
y el promedio del salario anual fue de
39 millones de pesos no definitivamente
no nadie en nuestra gráfica de
dispersión ganaba 39 millones de pesos
el promedio cada incremento de un millón
de pesos en el salario anual está
asociado con un incremento del 39 por
ciento en el porcentaje de victorias a
ver vamos a ver por aquí esta parte de
que cada incremento de un millón de
pesos está asociado con un incremento en
el porcentaje de victorias esto está
asociado con la pendiente de la línea de
tendencia y la pendiente no era 39 a ver
el promedio del porcentaje de victorias
fue de 39 por ciento no tampoco es el
caso y el modelo indica que los
entrenadores de los equipos cuyo salario
anual es de 0 millones de pesos tendrían
un porcentaje de victorias de
aproximadamente 39 por ciento si esta es
la opción que más se parece a lo que
estábamos diciendo acerca de lo que
significa la
de nada al origen de la línea de
tendencia si creemos en todo lo que
predice el modelo lo que la ordenada al
origen nos dice es que si un entrenador
gana 0 pesos al año su equipo tiende a
ganar el 39 por ciento de sus partidos y
es este tipo de detalles por los que uno
siempre tiene que ver los modelos con
mucha cautela porque ningún modelo puede
ser perfecto en todos los casos pero
bueno espero que te haya servido este
vídeo